here now is former nfl player and utah
congressman burgess owens and jack
beckett super bowl champion
and retired u.s army ranger all right
congressman
is your disagreement with gwen berry
based on her race
no it has to do with the reason why we
have olympics in the first place there's
a reason why
every country comes with their colors
they come with their flag because it's
about
love of nation about patriotism and i
tell you what's going to happen is she
she's going to end up being a very small
footnote because people are going to
forget her real soon but the message
behind this uh
judge is that we're going to recognize
and look at this is the moment our
president turned his back on our country
yeah because they have not standing up
against these uh these these cultural
marxists
he's he's he's he's actually allowing
them to do what they have to do because
he's afraid of them so
that's gonna be the message out of this
and america's gonna see this more and
more
that he's turning us back on our nation
and this is a good example by the way
if she doesn't love our country why
don't you just do something else do
do do get involved in some other way but
do not go and represent internationally
a nation
that's given this opportunity and she's
not going to be appreciative of it jake
um you know representative crenshaw
thinks that she should be
kicked off the olympic team what say you
well i think he's exactly right and so
is the congressman owens
uh he's a great american by the way but
when i played football at university of
arkansas and for the patriots
like standing on the sidelines before a
game watching that flag wave listening
to the anthem
standing side by side my teammates from
every race and background
look that scene right there represents
the greatness of america
and that scene is partly why after my
nfl career was over
i decided to join the army and i wore
that same flag on my right shoulder
when i served overseas 101st airborne
division in iraq
which was the greatest honor of my life
and how to turn around and to see some
athletes and even president biden
so such blatant disrespect and
ingratitude towards our flag in our
country
it's sickening look when you look at the
flag you have to think about the
generations of warriors
some who made the ultimate sacrifice so
that we as athletes like congressman
owens like myself like even gwen berry
can live free and play a game that we
love
that magnitude of that sacrifice
deserves and demands our respect
not our derision and the nation that
supports uh
our athletes to get to where they want
to go but gwen berry doubled down
on her disdain for the national anthem
yesterday
if you know your history you know the
full song of the national anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america
our blood being slain and and piltered
all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
congressman is it true there's no
question do you find this disrespectful
no it's very obvious he's very ignorant
of american
american history it was something that
karl marx said uh way back
the first battleground has been writing
of history our colleges are now
producing people like this
who go out there who can live the
american dream get the benefits of what
we have here and have no clue about who
what who paid the price what we did
together as americans across the board
including black americans who made made
this sacrifice to live the life she's
living right now
i lived it i understand it and during
the days of the 60s or the 60s
and what she's doing right now is an
affront to every single
uh generation of black americans who
stood far from this country and believed
in meritocracy and proved themselves
uh to be worthy to be called americans
you know joy behar
thinks that uh gwen berry is actually a
patriot
take a listen to this protest is the
very definition of patriotism
it basically is the basis of the country
she's basically doing her patriotic duty
by saying
i am making a point here that's all
she's doing
she's not hurting anybody what say you
jack jake well look there's a time and a
place for peaceful protest
but not while you're representing the
country in the olympics okay the whole
point of the olympics is you are
representing the united states of
america
you wear the flag on your uniform the
national anthem is played
when you win medals the flag is draped
over you
okay if you have a problem with america
if you have a problem with the flag
then you shouldn't participate in the
olympics it's that simple she should be
off the team
can i say this also judge who they're
hurting and who these people always
heard
are those who those who look up to
athletes like this those who don't have
a family don't have fathers
they're going to grow up hating our
country because they see their heroes
hating our country so yes
they're hurting the entire generation
particularly of those those
those folks are at risk the black
community are learning through these
kind of people
that this country is not for them and
that's the worst message you give to
anyone
in a country that gives so much so much
freedom and opportunity and you know
jake one of the things that
that that i object to is is the fact
that there is a time and a place for
this
and you know then you wonder if people
are so upset about this country what
have they
done to make it better have they even
voted have they voted in a school board
meeting and a local town council
you know they sat on a jury have they
done any of those things that
that maybe could change uh america if it
isn't what they think it should be
and i guess my last question to you jake
would be i mean
in the future should should should there
be
apparently the international olympic
team does not allow this
uh whereas this is not yet the
international olympics are you familiar
with that
well judge i think you're exactly right
i think it should be disallowed in the
future
but i think you're exactly right also
that i think people should have the
proper perspective
about how great this country is look if
you've served in uniform and seen what
i've seen in places like iraq
you have an immediate appreciation for
how tremendous and magnificent this
country truly is
and so i think if everyone had that
perspective they would think about
things like disrespecting the flag
a little bit differently yeah all right
congressman
jake thank you very much for being with
us tonight